foreign
that I don't ask for but I know she has
bad spending habits what would you do
about this situation
I've never had this happen to me
personally this is a new one this is a
new one
um
I would probably do one of two things
the passive part of me would probably
take this money and put it into an
account and let it just sit because
there's going to be a day that she comes
and asks for it back
um the more the the last four or five
years six or seven years John would tell
my mom hey mom I'm really working hard
to build a life uh with my wife our own
life and so
um I appreciate your gift I'm really
grateful for it but we want to make a go
at this on our own and so uh please feel
free to give that money to my brother my
sister whoever else yeah
as gentle as I can the problem has not
heard the problem is me don't bring up
the fact that she's too broke to give
nope wouldn't even go there wouldn't
even go there I would just say you know
I appreciate this and you're so sweet
um a I don't need it and B I'm trying to
practice
the discipline of living on my own and
it would be helpful to me if you would
give this to someone else my promise is
if I ever get desperate enough I'll call
you I won't go hungry I promise Mom and
you're so sweet and thank you thank you
but um I can't accept this anymore
because I'm trying to work on me and
just turn turn the whole thing back on
yourself and say yeah
yeah there's a the other one that comes
up is um and I've heard this one a bunch
of times over the years is uh mom and
dad are broke but mom keeps buying my
kids toys on
and trips and whatever grandparents
stuff Disney grandparents stuff on
credit cards and making making Mom and
Dad worse
how do I stop her from doing that and
it's a similar conversation on only this
one's even harder but it's like Mom
we're trying to limit what the kids are
getting and
um you know uh so we you just can't do
this anymore uh We've you've got to stop
you're gonna have to check with me
before you buy anything else
yeah and um and then again there's no it
it very seldom is positive to shame them
and go you're too broke to do this stop
it that doesn't work although that's a
true statement but
and it's tempting to say that but it's
really not profitable